All right.
Welcome to the TDPS seminar, everyone.
Before we introduce our invited speaker,
let's go over some rules as usual.
First of all, please unmute yourself
during the talk. If you have immediate
questions, you're welcome to unmute and
ask. Or otherwise, please use the chat
room to post your questions so that we
can address them in the Q&A session at
the end.
Second, today's seminar is open to
external audience, so no classified
discussion is allowed.
Finally, the talk will be record and
upload to our YouTube channel.
Now, let me introduce our speaker.
It is an honor to host Alice Cicirello,
um who is now a faculty member in the
engineering department of University of
Cambridge.
She is the founder and the head of the
data, vibration, and uncertainty group
and currently holds the Alexander von
Humboldt Foundation Research Fellowship
for experienced researchers.
Alice obtained her PhD from the
University of Cambridge in 2013.
Prior to her current position, she was
an associate professor and the head of
the section of mechanics and physics of
structures
in the engineering structures department
at TU Delft.
Her research interests span from
fundamental to applied research.
Her technical expertise covers
uncertainty quantification, machine
learning applied to measurements, tests,
and physics-based models, advanced
physics-based modeling and of nonlinear
systems,
and dynamic experimental testing and
monitoring of components, systems,
structures, and materials.
Today, she will talk about challenges
and opportunities in integrating physics
knowledge in machine learning strategies
with friction identification as case
study. Please enjoy the wonderful talk.
Now, without further ado, let me hand it
over to
Thank you so much, Si Boon. And thank
you all for being here. It's really
great to be able to talk to you about
this very, very exciting research that
has been going on in the data vibration
and uncertainty group.
To start with, let's see if my slides
actually flip. Yeah, I'm going to
describe
a general problem. So, if you consider
all of these type of structure that are
represented from satellite
to bridges
to actually friction brakes. And what
we're trying to do is what we do usually
is to try to model this system. And
what they have in common is that they
are subject to broadband type of
loading. They are complex structures
made of different components.
And what we try to do, apart from
modeling at design stage, is usually
also monitoring the structure to collect
the information. And once we have this
information, we also want to collect
other type of information that are
coming from, for instance, inspection
report, failure reports. And we have all
of these in a nutshell that is
describing what is happening to
engineering type of structure.
But what we have what we are facing all
the time with this type of broad range
of structure are actually three
engineering grand challenges. The first
one comes from the fact that we are
dealing with the design of this complex
system. And we are often often dealing
with uncertainty and nonlinearities.
Also, when we are trying to predict the
remaining useful life of this type of
structure during operating condition, we
have to deal with uncertainty,
nonlinearity, and sparse noise data. And
the other challenge, which is another of
the biggest one that we have at the
moment, is actually to apply machine
learning strategy
in engineering by developing these
techniques further developing them in a
way in which they can be explainable and
interpretable.
And uh what we try to do and our
ambition in the data vibration and
uncertainty lab is actually to use an
integrated approach to tackle these
three grand challenges. And the way
which we do so is to going from
laboratory experiments and physics-based
model to information extraction
techniques development to integrating
data measurements and model and also
developing uncertainty quantification.
And we try to do all of these with the
goal of guiding decision-making at the
design stage and also guiding
decision-making in operating condition
with the aim of reducing uh um
basically unexpected failure and
performance issues.
So, what we do within uh the group is
actually develop techniques that enable
us to perform these uh innovative
design exploration under uncertainties
and nonlinearity to assess the uh
remaining useful life of the structure
and extract this information from
different type of data that can come as
you I was saying to you before from
inspection data of the measurements,
historical data, images, and models.
Okay, this was to give you a general
idea of the challenges that we are
targeting. During this talk, I will talk
about uh there will be four main parts.
The first part is about
physics-enhancing machine learning. Why
we do this and how can we do that?
Then I'm going to focus on a specific
problem that we have in engineering that
is actually the identification of
friction. I will tell you about the
challenges and therefore and afterwards
I will tell you about the strategy that
we are implementing to solve this
challenge. And at the end I will talk
about challenges and opportunities in
physics-informed machine learning and
what are the steps going forward. And I
hope that many researchers will join me
in tackling these challenges.
So, probably the best place to start is
to say, "Okay, what are the application
of data driven techniques?" And
especially if we focus on
applied solid mechanics.
Well, there are three main branches in
which we can apply data driven
techniques. One is extracting
information, and the other one is
reducing computational cost. But of
course, we can use it also to improve
modeling and forecasting. And you can
see here are some example of how we can
extract information, how we can improve
the model, but also how we can reduce
the computational cost. And I mean, the
application is quite broad, and they've
been successfully used for many systems.
But what's the catch? Why we need
physics?
So, one of the thing to remember is that
that data is not enough.
Because data must be transformed in
information. And actually, we are making
a some inherent assumption when we talk
about the data that we are handling. And
uh
we are assuming that machine learning at
the end I'm going to just do this.
Sorry.
The inherent assumption that we are
making are that the data that we have is
informative.
That means can we actually distinguish
what are the sources that are generating
that type of data? What is the data that
we need? What do we monitor, when and
where we monitor?
We say that it's accurate, which means
that we are assuming that the
measurements that we are having are
actually close to the true value that
we're going to have. So, there is no no
noise or very low.
But also, we are assuming that the data
is reliable. What it means is that if
you repeat the measurements, we should
in the same condition, exactly the same,
we should get exactly the same behavior
even after a long period. Most of the
end, this is not the case. And indeed,
machine learning models are always as
good as the data.
And the data
first of all, most of the time doesn't
satisfy these inherent assumption that
we make. But also, we are not able to
observe all the conditions that we would
like to observe in the data.
And data can also come from different
completely different sources that have
different frequency and
spatial
uh resolution. And as a result of that,
what is happening is that we have to
deal with a complexity of data, and we
possibly noisy and missing data as well.
Now,
even if we have the, you know, the
perfect data set, and we are dealing
with this kind of problem,
there is actually a need, and there is a
big need to deal with physics and to
introduce physics in machine learning
strategies. And the reason uh probably
can be explained effectively by using
this sort of two-dimensional graph. On
the x-axis, you see that is displayed
the physics knowledge, while on the
y-axis, we have the data availability.
And again, data that is informative, not
just data for the sake of data.
And what we can do is that we can
distinguish nine areas with low, medium,
and high physics knowledge, and
correspondingly with informative data
availability. Now,
if we have lots of data, and we have
very, very little knowledge, machine
learning seems to be the way to go.
But most of the time
for engineering system, we actually have
physics knowledge. And if we have
physics knowledge, but we have very
little data, then definitely physics
modeling is the only thing that we can
do.
Most of the time, actually, we are in
between these two sort of extreme. We
are having some physics knowledge, and
we have access to data.
Now, the main challenge that we have in
engineering is that the volume of the
useful experimental data is actually
usually limited. We cannot collect much
information, it's difficult to place
sensors, costs is expensive, and it's
difficult to understand what to measure
and when to measure unless you know
exactly what you're looking for. And in
complex structure or large dimension,
this become a very big challenge.
Moreover, what's the big challenge? The
big challenge is that we we will need
anyway physics knowledge in order to be
able to generalize
our results in a regime that is actually
above the small medium data. And because
we want to also enforce physics with
large data, because there's always the
risk that we are not
then be able to account for physics.
What do I mean by that?
The meaning of of what I'm trying to say
is that machine learning is great, but
we should
take it
a cautious look at it when we use it as
a data-driven technique.
Because if we apply it as it is without
accounting for any physics constraints
or any physics knowledge, we might see
some poor generalization performance and
extrapolation and observational biases.
And we might also get physically
inconsistent or impossible prediction.
The reason why this occurs
it could be that, as I was telling you,
the data is very important and the
information that it carries. So, we can
have, for instance, corrupted
measurements, but also when we do
data-driven technique, what we observe
are actually correlation and association
and evidence. We don't see and we don't
have directly with the data-driven only
technique causal relationship, and we
cannot distinguish, unless we do
something about it,
their confounding sources.
As a result of that, using data-driven
techniques can lead to very accurate,
but very wrong prediction. So, that's
the reason why we always have to watch
out for only data-driven and why it is
important to also include physics if we
know, of course, the physics.
And uh in applied mechanics, uh you
know, an application related to applied
mechanics is actually it will
incorporate the physics knowledge.
So, what is the main reason? The main
reason is that differently to other
companies that maybe with the
data-driven techniques are giving
suggestion to watch something or to
listen to something or to buy something,
here we are actually supporting
decision-making. And this
decision-making can affect the behavior
of structure and can actually compromise
lives and
and can compromise performance as well
and cause problem. So, what we are
aiming at is actually
be able to guide decision-making. And
going beyond that black boxes. Because
what we would like to do is having
something that is both interpretable and
explainable. And what I mean by that uh
is the following. Interpretability will
respond to the answer how was a
prediction made. While explainability
will respond to can we communicate the
prediction to support decision-making.
Now, the key thing with the
interpretability and model being
interpretable is that we would like to
understand when it succeed or fail. We
would like to understand why that
happened. And the main reason is that at
the end humans will always trust more
prediction that are coming from
something that they can understand when
it fails and when it actually succeed.
The explainability actually it's related
to the fact that the prediction must be
comprehensible and capable also of
quantifying any remaining uncertainties
in the prediction. And the main reason
why this is so important is that at the
end the critical decision must be taken
by human and understandable
understandable actually should be
understandable by human because they
must be communicated to other humans.
So, because of this
we actually the way I see the problem is
that physics-informed machine learning,
scientific machine learning, physics
analysis machine learning, as you want
to like it, becomes an integration
challenge.
And and it is an integration challenge
for the reason that I'm going to explain
to you. And
I'm going to try to divide the problem
into. I'm going to talk first about
modeling and forecasting, and then I'm
going to talk about the inverse problem.
If you look at the
modeling and forecasting, we look at the
applied solid mechanics challenges, you
can see on the left a list of the things
that we are still dealing with. And that
makes
doing modeling and forecasting very
complex for multi-physics and
multi-scale system.
What we have to remember is that we want
to also integrate heterogeneous noise
data and domain knowledge that might be
available. But also we have to deal with
uncertainties.
If we look instead at the inverse
problem, in which we basically have some
data, some information, and we want to
go back
to
model.
What we usually deal with is what you
see on the right. Those are the
challenges. We might have an unknown
physical parameter, unknown physical
laws, unknown material constitutive law,
but we might have also a gap in noisy
boundary condition, and partially
unknown governing equation.
What it makes it even more complex is
that we are often dealing with small and
heterogeneous data. We have
multi-fidelity data. And we have
compounding influences that affect the
results.
And of course, if you think about the
model, we may have a high-dimensional
problem and computational cost become
very important. All of these sees also
uncertainties as another challenge.
So, to me, physics-informed machine
learning is actually this integration
challenge that goes beyond just saying
we have data and data-driven model and
physics-based model. It's actually
something that says we have mathematical
models, we have this data, but we have
also this multi-fidelity data challenge.
This non-informative data that might be
there and we might want to get rid of it
because maybe it's affecting the
results, it's biasing the results. The
corrupted data.
We also want to account for domain
knowledge, physical laws, prior
knowledge, and appropriate biases
actually that we can implement. And of
course, all of this comes with the
challenge of interpretability and
explainability of the results.
And accounting for the uncertainty. It's
a different level. Uncertainty in the
physics knowledge, uncertainty in the
data, and also in the learning model
that we're using.
Okay, so I hope that this makes sense so
far about the general context about what
is physics physics in machine learning
of physics enhanced machine learning and
the integration challenge. But now we
can think about how can we incorporate
physics to enhance machine learning
strategies? They are so powerful,
they're already so widespread. How can
we take make the most out of them? And
there are four ways in which we can
integrate
knowledge and they can be all combined
to accelerate training and enhance
generalization.
The first one is to look at
observational biases. We can introduce
data that is actually extracted from
different forces sources that embody the
physics that we want to capture. And
therefore, we can augment our data set.
Another thing that we can do is to
introduce an inductive bias. So we can
incorporate any prior assumption about
the physical constraints, but also about
for instance, boundaries, conservative
laws, symmetries, and we can embed these
in the architecture of the learning
algorithm. So they are explicitly there.
Another way that we can look at the
problem is to look at the way in which
we construct our learning algorithm. So
how we define the loss function, the
regularization constraints, and what
inference learning algorithm we select.
And finally, of course, another bias
that we can incorporate is what we know
about the physics. If we know partially
the equation, we know the model form, or
we know the discrepancy bias, some term
of the equation, we can actually
introduce them.
And those are the general four ways in
which we can do this. And one way to see
this probably in a very nice and neat
way is to look at a general example of a
neural network architecture in which we
can include the physics knowledge. So,
I'm going to just go very briefly
through it to give you an idea. So, what
we have by this neural network
architecture in which we have some input
layers and one output layers. And what
you see inside is these hidden layers.
We have a number of nodes per layer. It
doesn't matter that much. They can be
fully connected or not. It's just for
the sake of understanding what is
happening. What we can do is that we can
have we can use this neural network
architecture actually to understand and
to derive a partial differential
equation. And what we can do is to we
can actually enforce some of the other
constraints on the output of the neural
network that we're learning. And what we
can do then is feed this information, a
partially known governing equation. As a
result, what is happening then, we can
look at the loss between the output
layer and the results obtained with the
governing equation. And then we can
update our knowledge. What you see here
are the different ways in which in which
we can introduce the bias. We can
introduce the observational bias that
act only on the input layer, for
instance. We can do we can introduce the
inductive bias in the way we actually
put the architecture together. For
instance, we could use CNN or any other
architecture. Then we have a learning
bias in the way that we define the loss
function of our problem. And finally,
the discrepancy a is the fact that we
are already embedding these results
within partially known governing
equation. So, I hope that again this
makes sense and now it's clearer for the
audience
the ways in which the forum biases and
how we can introduce it.
But
what is the physics informed machine
learning strategy? It's not just neural
networks. And actually, there is no
one-size-fits-all. There is not just one
strategy. There is not just one way of
doing it. It really depends on the
complexity of the system, on the amount
of informative data, and the purpose.
What's the reason why we are doing all
of this? And depending on that, we might
use a completely different technique and
a different way of biasing the
information. So, the way in which I I
will try then to explain how we can
implement this in general is to show you
four main path for formulating physics
enhanced machine learning. And of
course, this is very much biased towards
application in applied mechanics, and
I'm not
claiming that I'm going to tell you all
the possible ways of doing it. But one
main way for doing it is that our goal
is say there is to learn unknown physics
terms or learning the equation. And we
start from interpretable observable
variables. So, the path that will lead
us to learn these unknown terms of the
equation is usually to collect data to
formulate some physics using dictionary
of operators on inputs or or part of the
equation, and then we can apply learning
algorithm with or without physics
constraint. That's actually what we can
do in general. And one of these examples
is of course PINs, but also sparse
system identification strategy can
actually
fall into this category because we can
possibly also include some explicit
constraint there.
Another way of seeing the problem of
formulating a physics enhanced machine
learning strategy is to look at learning
useful from informative rules on our
reduced order model. And uh the way the
path that it leads to us is to start
again from data observation, and maybe
we want to apply some manifold learning
autoencoders, and we want to determine
this reduced
reduced latent space that then will give
us these informative rules or this
reduced order model. And uh the way one
very simple way to I mean explain this
is to think about having an input layer
and then going into a latent space or
code. Again, we can have a neural
network architecture, and then basically
we have we want to go back to an output
layer. So, we have an encoder phase, and
then we have a decoder phase. You can
see how the slides I've got to I've put
like reference to say see some papers
from these groups because many groups
have been working on this, and it would
be too long to put all the relevant
references.
Another path to formulating physics
enhanced machine learning is actually
quantifying the uncertainties in the
parameters terms of a non-physics based
model. And there we can start from a
non-physics based model with uncertain
input parameters. And what we can do is
collect noisy data, and then apply some
learning algorithm with or without the
physical constraints. And a very simple
example is probabilistic machine
learning strategy with a non-physics
model, in which we have a non-physics
and noisy for instance dynamic response
measurements that are combined together
to define the likelihood that is the
discrepancy between what we observe and
the model prediction, and combining with
the prior distribution that represent
our prior knowledge. Now, the reason to
do that is that by knowing the prior and
the likelihood, we can then calculate
what is called the posterior
distribution, therefore updating our
knowledge.
Then, finally that we have the fourth
path, and again they are not
all exclusive. The fourth path to
physics enhanced machine learning is to
quantify uncertainties in the parameter
term of a partially known physics-based
model. And there we start from this
partially known physics-based model that
has an uncertain with
with an uncertain functional form. It
means that we don't know actually which
is the functional form of the term that
we would like to obtain. And again, we
can collect noisy data, and we can apply
some learning algorithm with physics
constraints.
For example, the Gaussian process later
force model or the physics analysis
sparse identification actually do that
by introducing a discrepancy bias and
then learning something about the
system.
Okay. So, I hope that this was a gentle
introduction to the problem and that
you're all still with me following
because now I would like to talk about
the identification of friction and which
are the challenges and why we need
physics in machine learning to solve
this.
Okay. So,
this is a very nice example, I believe,
because friction
is actually something that we see every
time in our life. And basically, it's
this force that is resisting the
relative motion of surfaces sliding
against each other. And friction is the
reason why when you're walking, you
actually don't fall and you don't slide
like crazy, but you can walk actually on
different surfaces.
And
there are some pros and cons of having
friction in structural engineering,
especially in joint structure. The pro
is, of course, that it is a very good
way of dissipating energy and reducing
vibrational amplitude. But there are
actually also some drawbacks like it can
cause wear, noise, large acceleration.
And especially, stick-slip phenomena.
And I'm going to show you a video later
on to explain what is stick-slip for the
people that don't know about it. But all
of these phenomena actually can reduce
the remaining useful life of structure
and then lead to sudden failures.
And the main problem with friction is
that it cannot be directly measured. If
you have Imagine you have a joint and
you want to measure the friction, the
force between two parts, if you open it,
then there's no more friction, of
course. And if you put a sensor, you're
changing the way in which the joint
behave. And of course, if you put a
sensor, then
probably
there will be aging of sensor and of the
equipment. And so, you don't want
actually, first of all, to change the
joint, but second of all, you don't want
to start having measurements that might
be wrong. Even if you could.
So, what we would like to do then is to
basically to go towards what is a
real-time
monitoring of a frictional force
evolution. And the idea is not to
measure friction where it happens, but
to measure the response. And from the
response, go back and actually
characterize friction.
What you see here is basically the work
that I've been doing with Luca and in a
nutshell with Dr. Luca Marinò. And this
representing in a nutshell. And he start
He started with a problem that was given
by an engineering company in which they
were
basically problem once the joint of the
after root of a gas turbine blade was
changed. And there Therefore, there we
understood that friction was a problem
that we didn't understand properly, and
we started doing very simple, you know,
single degrees of freedom analysis,
building an experimental setup. And what
we discovered that it was very
interesting is that the similarly to
what we see in viscous problem, there is
a sort of magic point in the frequency
ratio. And you can see it actually here.
And what this magic voice tells you is
that uh
if you increase friction, you usually
reduce the amplitude that is motion that
is transmitted. But there is this magic
point above which, above this frequency
ratio, you increase friction, and
instead of reducing motion, you're
actually amplifying it. And therefore,
this can be something very interesting
and to account when we have also our
physics
in form model.
And we just we
understood this numerically,
analytically, but also we tested this
with the experimental setup.
And we did the lots of investigation
that enabled us to understand so so much
better the physics of the problem. The
then it felt natural to actually include
this in a machine learning architecture.
And
what I'm going to do to try to explain
the problem of friction possibly in a
better way is to explain to you what is
this test setup. And this test setup is
actually a very simple system in which
we have a base plate that is the things
that you see here. There is this
mechanism here that actually through a
motor is making these things move up and
down using an harmonic kind of
excitation. And you can see here that
there are these sort of bars. And these
bars are the same that actually connect
the base plate with the top plate. And
this is an aluminum plate at the top.
And what you can see as well is that we
are adding a a contact balance system.
And here we have basically this mass
that is sitting on top. So this distance
that is sitting on top of the top plate.
And that is where friction the friction
force actually occur.
This is a brass
element that is in contact with this
aluminum
plate.
And
what you see
here basically
is
is going to be this video in which I'm
going to show you what is happening when
we have stick slip. So we are focusing
our attention in this area over here.
And we are exciting the system by making
this move up and down basically.
And what you will see are different ways
in which the
disk mass here, this top plate will
start moving because of the contacts.
Okay.
So,
see if the video works.
It say that cannot play the the media.
Great then.
Okay. So, if the video was working
because before it was working, you would
have seen a continuous motion and then
the stick slip. So, the mass within a
cycle of motion will be sticking and
then sleeping and then going backwards
in a sort of symmetric way.
Sorry for this.
Things like this happen all the time,
unfortunately.
Um what we have understood by this
problem
by investigating the physics of this
type of problem and thanks also to the
experimental setup is that the most
robust feature that actually can enable
us to understand what is the friction
force and to characterize actually the
friction problem is actually the
friction versus velocity.
And the challenges that we are facing I
I will spare you all the description of
how we came up to this conclusion, but I
can tell you that there are several
papers investigating this phenomenon.
The challenge there is how to obtain the
friction force versus velocity graph
from experiments in which we are
actually obtaining measurements. And
these measurements are not at the
contact away from the contact as the
master is moving. And especially when
this phenomenon of stick and then slip
occurs. And every time there is a stick
and then slip, there is a sudden release
of energy and then we go back and forth.
So, our strategy is actually to use
physics informed machine learning. And
of course, we use
uh we use three machine learning
strategy. And I'm going to describe
these three different physics informed
machine learning strategy to do so.
And I'm going to build up
in complexity and
will be very happy to take any question
you might have at any point. So, please
start writing if you want.
So, the first strategy is to build up on
the sparse system identification. And
basically what we did was looking at the
extended sparse system, developing
actually the extended sparse system
identification. What we did there was
actually introducing two biases, one
observational bias and one inductive
bias.
The first bias consists of partitioning
the data in stick and then sleep data
motion. And the inductive bias instead
is looking at the dictionary of function
and exploiting stick sleep and temporal
constraint.
So, you see on the right some results,
but I'm going to explain to you which
are the steps. And what I would like to
stress is that this work was led by
Saurabh Marjan. And you can find more
information about this approach in the
paper listed there.
So, how does it work? So, there is Cindy
and I'm going to explain you in a second
what it is. And Cindy has been developed
by Brunton and collaborators. So, you
can see there the
main paper.
So, basically you take some
measurements, you select some candidate
features, and you obtain some sparse
governing equation. But let me unwrap to
you for you what does what does this
mean? Say that you have a set of
governing equation that is represented
in this form, in general form. And you
actually don't know which is this
relationship. And that's what we want to
obtain. What we can do is to make an
approximation. So, we have a set of
candidate function theta and then
multiply by a coefficient.
And what we can then say is that okay,
this looks very much like I mean you
remember what we do with finite element
methods, we have the base function and
we multiply that
basically
to obtain at the end this
approximation. And what we do there is
to say "Okay, we have an adaptive bias
because we have a
library of candidate function that the
user can give us input."
And then we have this sparse
coefficient, and those are the
coefficient that we want to find. So,
basically it's like saying the
approximation is going to be made of all
of these possible function, each of them
multiplied by this sparse coefficient,
and depending on the value of this
sparse coefficient, some of these terms
will be dropped. Some other terms will
remain. So, that's actually what is
happening with sparse system
identification.
And the way in which this is done is to
solve actually this
this type of problem in which we are
minimizing what we are measuring with
respect to what we are predicting. And
we have this threshold this emotional
threshold 3 squared approach in which
alpha is actually
a parameter that is given by the user,
and that determines how much we're going
to retain, and which is the lowest value
that we're going to retain.
And Cindy's greatest been applied to
many plastic type of problem, but it
might be sensitive to a noise level, and
there is an automatic differentiation
inside of it that will make the the
problem becoming unstable.
And what we have observed, especially
for friction in which you have
discontinuous behavior, is that we we
basically have poor performance that
will lead to no smooth response.
This is due to the fact that when we
have this friction force, we have this
discontinuity basically in the behavior
that leads to this stick motion this
sticking and then sudden motion. And
what we then developed is this extended
Cindy. And the way in which it works is
pretty straightforward. Based on the
fact that we have either mass motion and
mass sticking, so either we have
something that is stuck there or mass
moving, and this happen in time
basically. It can happen and we can have
multiple stops.
What we we going to do is to segregate
the data based on the velocity condition
into mass motion and mass sticking.
That's the first step.
Then what we can do is to apply SINDy
directly to the mass motion data.
The reason why we want to do that is to
get the correct equation of motion.
However, we will get the wrong
coefficient.
The reason for this is that uh it's not
still capable to It doesn't It doesn't
have already all the information, all
the data. And the fact that it's
assuming that there is not a data
obtained during sticking is actually
giving us a wrong uh
a wrong result.
Then what we can do is to apply some
constraints that are based on our
physics knowledge and about what
happened when we have mass motion and
mass sticking. And by doing this, what
we can get at the end are these two
surfaces, the lower bound and the upper
bound. The lower bound will represent
the stick and the upper bound is that is
looking at the stick condition. Finally,
what we can do is to find the parameters
of the model, the correct ones. So then
now we can identify the system. And
basically, what this figure is showing
is are these lower bound and upper bound
surfaces that you will see in terms of
the friction behavior. And what we are
looking for is exploring this domain in
order to find the parameter K and C. In
this case, for a single degrees of
freedom system with spring stiffness K
and C as the damper. And we were
interested in looking at this minimum
distance and therefore finding what
would be then the value of the system.
What's the goal with extended SINDy? At
the end, we get out of it
this governing equation. And once you
have the governing equation, in
principle, we are fully generalizable
because then we can investigate
whichever problem. So from measurements,
we want to go to the governing equation
by applying some physical strains
knowledge. And of course, going through
this data segregation.
Okay. So what you see now here to the
left is what happened when we have
continuous motion, when we have a two
stop or a four stop within a cycle. So,
within a cycle of the base moving, we
can have at the top either two stops or
four stops or no stops.
Now, the extended Cindy, when of course
there are no stops, it falls back to
Cindy because at the end we don't need
to segregate the data. So, what is
happening is that it's going to be
continuous motion and what you see here
are actually the results that we will
get by applying Cindy. And if we
consider the RMSE error compared to the
actual solution, we will see that it's
actually very small. And what we see is
that
our governing equation are actually very
good at capturing the behavior. But of
course, what we see is that there is a
sort of degradation as soon as we go
higher in terms of number of stops and
this is because of the discontinuity
that is coming. And in fact, the Cindy
applied to even if we consider the
motion
part only, Cindy might perform poorly
for this kind of problem because of the
small data set.
And what we see then is that the two
stop and the four stop problem, the
governing equation and the difference
between Cindy and extended Cindy. And
what we notice with this
that is very important, especially for
the four stop, is that Cindy might
completely mislead the results and then
generate a governing equation that
doesn't see these multiple stops.
While the extended Cindy can.
But still, the problem is that this kind
of approach is sensitive to noise level
because it's requiring an automatic
differentiation. And we have observed
that there is still not a great
performance as the number of stops
increases.
And of course, it would be nice to
account also for uncertainties in the
results and at the moment we cannot do.
So, this was the first way which we
introduced some knowledge
of the system by
basically doing this extended Cindy and
and showing what is the potential and
what is the need especially when we are
dealing with the multiple stops. And you
see especially here what is happening to
the problem to the case under
investigation.
Um
I'm not going to There are other two
techniques and what I'm going to focus
now is
another approach that we developed. And
this strategy is based on a switching
partial latent force model.
In this case, we are assuming that we
know also the model. Before, we didn't
say that we knew the model of the
system. We didn't know anything about
the partial governing equation. We
wanted to obtain the full function.
Now, we have the discrepancy bias and we
say that we have a set of latent forces.
We say that because we know that we have
a stick and slip, we're going to have
our latent forces going to be
representing stick, another one that is
going to represent slip, and then we're
going to have also the set mode.
And then
we can embed also the stick slip
constraint. So, we can add some
inductive bias.
Of course, our system, our learning
algorithm will be also affected by the
stick slip behavior and we're going to
have a learning bias also introduced.
The key things here
is that we have no knowledge of the
functional form. We are not making any
assumption. We don't have a dictionary
of function that might actually help
guess what is going to happen to the
system. And because we have no knowledge
of the functional form, what it means is
that we are trying to get something like
the result shown in the right. We would
like to get from the data set. Remember,
we are not measuring friction force
versus velocity. We are measuring
displacement actually. And what we want
to do is to get back to this
relationship. And the way in which we
can do that is to combine what we know
and what we don't know. And so basically
we have the physics model, the dynamics
response measurement, and we also
measure the input
given to the system.
What we apply then is a Gaussian process
latent force model. And the way in which
it works is similarly to this and bear
with me with the some very simple
equation. We have a two degrees of
freedom system
characterized by a mass m, by a dashpot
c, and by a stiffness k. And we have
this force that is actually the unknown
term, this f, and this is actually our
frictional force that we would like to
characterize. For it we don't know
anything
any form or nothing.
And we know the input measurement u g
that is given to the system. What we do
is to consider a Gaussian process model
with a stationary kernel. And this is a
zero mean Gaussian process.
If we apply
just as it is the Gaussian process
latent
What we see
is that we can predict
the displacement is what we measure and
so our model then is still getting very
well the displacement, but if we look at
the nonlinear force versus time
evolution or the nonlinear force versus
velocity evolution, you can see some
striking features. We have uncertainties
now. We can look at the bounds of the
uncertainties.
But we have all the time smoothed at the
response. And this is because it's the
Gaussian process that is dealing
actually,
uh, with smooth
um, function type.
And what is happening, uh, that is
especially important is that if we look,
uh, here at these results,
uh, when we look at the normalized force
versus velocity, we see that there is an
incorrect, uh, frictional force
description when the velocity is zero.
This is particularly challenging because
then if we want to use this model to
generalize and to be applied in
different system, we going to see and
especially for more stick-slip kind of
phenomena, it's going to actually give
us much more problems.
Okay, so what was the solution to this?
The solution is to not just consider
Gaussian process later force model, but
a switching Gaussian process later force
model.
So, basically we're going to have a set
of of zero mean GP prior.
And basically what we then try to
calculate with this approach is the
posterior distribution by Kalman
filtering smoothing.
The switching model as I was telling you
are considering the state of the system
that we know will happen. No matter how
many stick-slip phenomena we will have,
we can have either a sliding condition,
a sticking condition, or we can go in
what is called a resetting mode. And the
resetting mode is for accounting
for taking into account discontinuities
in the latent friction model.
So, what we got to do is to build
actually a sequence of linear Gaussian
state space model. And we're going to
build it by using this type of equation
that are exemplified here.
And basically in a nutshell, what is
happening is that we start with these
noise measurements with these driving
force and the system parameters.
We have to set up what is the kernel of
our Gaussian
process basically, the number of the
linear Gaussian state model that we're
going to use, the number of Gaussian
that we're going to consider in our
assumed density field and in our
expectation correction.
And what you see then, this is the sort
of architecture that is happening within
the the switching GPLVM. This is much
more complex than looking of course into
a sparse system identification kind of
approach because we have to calculate
the GPLVM parameters by using some
sampling technique. And we try to do
that using what is called the
variational base Monte Carlo to reduce
computational cost. But we have also
applied some filtering and smoothing.
Uh
At the end of these results, we actually
got the nonlinear force and the motion
regime transition and discontinuity.
This approach is very powerful and this
is actually shown in these results in
which you can see what is happening in
terms of the displacement,
velocity, acceleration, force, but also
model. The model as I was saying there
are three model. There's stick, the
slip, and the reset model. And actually
automatically is able to distinguish,
thanks to a Markov model,
um what is actually the condition that
will release the correct model. And what
you see here is that we are able to also
detect and capture what is happening in
terms of the um very difficult and sharp
corner of the response. And these are
the final results that we got that it's
uh telling us that we are
confidently then obtaining the friction
force, the velocity, but also the
uncertainty bounds in our prediction.
The main challenge with this type of
approach that we
There's still things that needs to be
done is that at the moment can be only
applied for one type of nonlinearity.
And of course we are facing the
dimensionality issue that comes with the
Gaussian process which is great, but if
we are looking at the dimension that are
higher than 20, then we start to have
problems with it.
So we then try to look at at the best of
two worlds of what we have seen so far.
And one of these is then then we come up
with this physics-enhanced sparse
identification.
And with this
kind of approach, we actually want to
have the partial model as we have in the
previous approach that I described to
you,
but we want to leverage on Cindy as well
and on especially on what is called
archive or the so we want to account for
the longitudinal scheme
in order to reduce the space of the
possible solution. So we want to have a
discrepancy bias and inductive bias and
a learning bias.
And what is shown just to give you a
feeling for what we mean by having also
this event condition or this
information about the stick and slip
having embedded it the physics knowledge
not where it happened but just a
condition that we need to that
happening. You can see on the right what
is happening in terms of displacement in
the top and velocity versus time. And
again this is a single degrees of
freedom just for the purpose of showing
showcase some results. And this is when
we apply Cindy
with an event condition
without an event condition and what is
the ground truth. You can see that even
if we have the right information and the
right model
not including the event condition
creates lots of problem in terms of
really capturing the displacement and
the velocity behavior of the system.
And of course the governing equation.
That's what you can see with condition
and without condition. It seem trivial
seem just a small difference but this is
then affecting completely the results
and how generalizable these results are.
You can find more information about this
in this relevant paper.
So how does this active forcing the
works and how can we get out of it
generalizable generalizable non-linear
differential equation?
So we imagine that we have
a
basically a a system of a equation of a
sort of differential equation.
And we can imagine that basically we
know the unknown functional we know
basically part of the results. So we
know the discrepancy bias.
But
so we know part of the equation but we
don't know a functional form of one
term.
And what we're trying to do there is to
say, "Okay, we start from a time series
of noisy and sparsely collected
measurement, and we want to obtain out
of it uh basically the governing
equation, and especially this part of
the unknown functional form."
The way in which this work is again to
consider basically this uh sparse system
identification in which we approximate
half as the product of these candidate
function and these sparse coefficient.
But now we are changing the way in which
we are making the prediction, and which
uh we are calculating the prediction. In
fact, we are going through a step that
is the RK4, so the Runge-Kutta scheme.
This was introduced in 2022
by Goyal and Benner. And what we've done
there is actually introducing within the
RK4 uh changing the learning algorithm.
We added some constraint, and we added
part of the knowledge of the function
that we have. What it means is that we
are having basically a learning bias
directly embedded in the system. We have
an inducted bias in terms of the
candidate function, and what we want to
obtain again are these sparse
coefficient.
The
the key warning here every time when we
work with
this kind of sparse system
identification is that measurements can
be always be fitted with uh just
polynomials. So, we have to be careful
about the inductive bias that we give in
terms of the library of candidate
function.
And uh of course the equations are
generalizable only if the candidate
function are the correct candidate
function are used. But the advantage of
this type of approach is that the RK4 uh
and all the constraints and physical
constraints are actually limiting the
space of possible solution, and
therefore are helping the identification
of a sparse solution that is the correct
one.
So, one thing that is very important to
stress is the importance of including
the correct physics in the problem
description. And again, I'm going to use
a very simple single degrees of freedom
system which we have this governing
equation. And as a measurement
available, we have the top plate
displacement and the base plate
displacement. And we have a discrepancy
bias because we know part of the model
and we want to focus on the friction
term that we don't know.
Now, we have a list of library boundary
function that can include polynomials,
signum function, cosine at different
frequency. And we are actually deciding
on purpose to include only first order
polynomials. I will be clear in a second
why this.
And we're going to consider three cases.
When the measurements of the base
excitation are provided, when we don't
have base of the excitation, and
basically um
we we don't know what it is and we have
to learn all of it. And when we assume
actually that we have a perfect harmonic
base excitation. There is actually a
wrong physics because the system is not
able to actually give a perfect harmonic
base excitation.
What we see here are the results. Let me
walk you through this. So again, the
black line is with measurement of base
uh excitation.
The green line is no base excitation and
it's not a driven and we see no
convergence and this is also because we
are using first order polynomial. And
you can see in terms of the results that
actually is not able to really
uh produce some credible results. But
also, if we assume that we have a
perfect harmonic results, so we have the
wrong physics,
we actually get the correct displacement
and velocity. But then, when we look at
the question C and we compare it to the
ground truth, you can see that is very
very different. And this is affecting
then how generalizable is the system.
And in fact, we are missing the signum
term. There is actually the friction
term. So we are not able to actually
identify correctly the problem if we
make some uh some wrong physics
assumption. This is something very
important to underline.
And uh
one of the challenges that we have
tackled with this approach, with this
physics and non-sparse identification,
is actually embedding as much physics as
we can and understanding which are the
limit of the physics that we can embed.
And one important uh problem that we
have is actually when we have friction
law, that might be undistinguishable in
certain parameter range. So, without
going into many details, we have the
Coulomb friction law and the DR friction
law. And in some parameter space, and
these parameters are representing
actually the DR law, in some parameter
space Coulomb and DR are exactly the
same. You cannot distinguish them when
you look at the mass displacement versus
force signal of the input base.
And this is interesting because this
poses a very difficult problem for the
inverse where we are trying to identify
the friction force.
And what we looked at is exactly this
case in which both the DR and Coulomb
actually give this displacement versus
forcing
uh that is pretty much the same.
So, what we did was considering this
candidate this set of candidate function
because we assume that we know what is
basically the friction behind the the I
mean, we assume that we know that there
is a friction problem. We don't know
what it is.
And uh and then and then what we trying
to do basically is to um apply Ising
with all the constraints that I
described to you with all the biases to
identify the correct governing equation.
And in case A, the ground truth is
Coulomb
and what you can see is that Ising is
able to identify correctly
uh the results. And in the second case,
the ground truth is actually generated
by looking at this and of course we have
noisy measurement.
Uh it's not perfect data. And you can
see that Ising is able to actually
identify correctly the governing
equation.
And this is exciting because it shows
that actually even in our parameter
space in which everything was pretty
much the same. And uh it's very
difficult for any type of system
identification technique to distinguish
between the two.
Even just by looking at the data and by
applying that physical constraints, we
are able to uh with the
physics in the to actually go back to
the correct governing equation. The main
challenge here is that we still don't
actually account for uncertainty
quantification. That's actually the next
step of
what we're working on at the moment.
Okay. So, this concludes the case
studies and the three strategies about
the friction identification. We are
actually have applied We actually have
applied also physics-informed machine
learning for other problems like
accounting for special and temporal
measurement correlation when we are
doing Bayesian system identification.
And we apply this for a bridge case
study. But also we have looked at
virtual sensing for wind turbine's
problem. And we are looking at way in
which we are actually able to calculate
what is happening below the mud line
when we are measuring only at the top
tower. So, please have a look at the
paper if you want to know more about
this.
And this concludes almost concludes my
talk because now we'd like to talk about
the challenges and opportunities for
IML. Of course, I show you some
techniques and some approaches and what
we have done to address those
challenges. But there are still many
more
There are important like into account.
Um one is the data biases. And I
mentioned this at the very beginning and
I would like to stress again that if you
have data that is not accurate, you will
get
accurate but wrong prediction. And this
is again because we don't have causal
relationship and that's difficult to
distinguish confounding influence when
we are looking just at data and we don't
account for physics.
And of course, we have to account for
the fact that the data set can be not
complete and corrupted.
What it means is that there is still a
lot that needs to be done to be able to
remove inappropriate data biases like
corrupted data from the data set that we
use.
And there are challenges as well in
integrating information of different
quality, but also in defining metrics
that assess the information quality,
especially that coming from data.
Another thing that I mentioned and I'll
show you to you especially
one case study is what happened if we
embed the wrong physics bias. And in
that case we said, "Okay, we know that
input the input is harmonic." And it
wasn't. And again we get very accurate
but completely wrong prediction. And the
main reason to explain this visually is
that if we imagine a solution space in
the 2D, it's like we are saying, "Okay,
this is the physics." So we are
constraining our search space in that
area there.
And we can get an approximate solution,
but this is completely far off from the
correct solution.
And again, embedding physics is very
important, but we have to make sure that
the physics that we embed is actually
constraining correctly the problem. So
there are challenges and opportunities
in improving physics model and
knowledge, but also detecting and
removing inappropriate biases that
otherwise will not help us exploring
completely the solution space. And of
course incorporating multiple physics
model.
Finally, there are many more challenges
in physics and also machine learning,
especially in applied like solid
mechanics. And of course this is again a
biased view because this is my view on
the problem. But I think that there are
many of these challenges related to
explainability and interpretability. The
fact that maybe we are using different
algorithms that return the same
performance on training data. But we
actually
we have to validate that and validation
is one of the biggest challenges that we
are having. And also understanding what
is the balance between the physics that
we want to embed and the data that we
want to use for general in session.
Many more that are listed here
as challenges and many more that are not
listed and that many researchers in the
world are working on. And with this I
would like to conclude my presentation
and thank you all for your for the
attention and if you want to know more
about the research we are doing or read
the paper, I would strongly encourage
you to look at the website
here. So, thank you so much.
Thank you for the wonderful talk, Alice.
Now, we are maybe a little time for the
Q&A section. So, right now we don't have
any questions yet in the chat room. So,
if the audience have any questions,
please feel free to unmute yourself.
So, probably I can kick off, but I must
say that I have very limited knowledge
about the frictional models. So, my
question is maybe very fundamental.
So,
my first question is like is the library
used in the extended Cindy the same as
the original Cindy?
Yes, the library is the same. So, what
we are assuming is that we have the same
level of knowledge
to avoid
any sort of additional bias because even
in Cindy you have already that bias
there inductive bias that you can
introduce and actually you should.
It's it's literally the only difference
with the with the Cindy the pure Cindy
is given by applying these constraints
that can separate the data basically.
The data during motion and during stick.
And again, Cindy is very powerful, but
the problem is that we have this uh
uh discontinuous non-linearity in the
problem that actually affect the data
set. So, it's like having a system that
is always continuously motion, a system
that is always like stuck and Cindy is
trying to get something that is in
between basically. So that's the reason
why it's not able to to get fully I mean
very simplistic way to imagine what is
happening and it is because continuously
the system is changing state is changing
from one state to the other.
I see. So I I feel like the sign
function appears in both of your
libraries and like difficulties is like
identifying the coefficients for that
function particularly. So
Yes. Is that correct?
Yes.
Finding that coefficient is one of the
challenges but actually what we observed
is that that is not the only challenge
because if we apply Cindy as it is
without physics knowledge then for a
system for a mass spring system you will
still have the answer I mean you still
not know precisely the mass of the
stiffness and actually if you apply
Cindy as it is also those coefficient
will be wrong. It will be actually
because it's trying to compensate. It
doesn't understand what is happening.
The data set is not fully giving the
information that Cindy needs and
therefore what is happening is that
they're going to be mistakes both in M K
but also on the friction. So that's
actually what we have observed
with the approach.
I see.
So
maybe I can ask one more. So maybe some
particular details of the algorithm that
I am interested in like can you go back
to page 27 if I remember correctly about
the
uh
you list a workflow about the extended
Cindy. Yes.
So
maybe yeah I I know it is not
appropriate to like add all the details
in in the slide but
uh
So I want to know what exactly is the
extra cost if I won't like use this
extra
instead of Cindy like is it more
expensive to identify the system there?
Thank you for asking this question. This
is very interesting. So we are using
Cindy in the second step. So the
computational cost that is Cindy pretty
much. There's nothing else.
But we have to do the data segregation
that is very fast because you take
basically a time series analysis and you
just say motion of motion. So you have a
velocity condition. So that's super
fast.
And the application of the constraints
and actually the minimization of this
distance between this blue and orange
surface is actually not computationally
expensive because although it's looking
at C and K and it seems that it's
sweeping through all different dynamic
analysis. Actually it's looking at the
constraint function. So what it means is
that is not re-running any analysis.
It's actually just looking for the
solution in this space. So
computationally is pretty much the same
as
of Cindy. Okay. But as I mentioned this
type of approach is still only
applicable to very simplified system to
a single degrees of freedom. When we
scale up or when we look at multiple
discontinuities
we start seeing deterioration. That's
why we went for the physics in form.
What we realized was that without
embedding even more physics it was very
difficult then to obtain accurate
results that are then generalizable in
terms of having an equation that can be
applied into different condition.
I see. So when I look at this workflow
again more closely I believe
that really means the lasso or the
sequential thresholding least squares
still applies here, right? Yes.
I see. Okay. Yes, exactly. Yeah. And in
fact as I told you
as I mentioned sorry, it goes into this
step. So it's when you apply Cindy that
actually you have to basically
do that and then here is just a
correction for the coefficient. As you
were saying that you would get
signal coefficient that is wrong then
there would be the mass and stiffness
that is wrong. So by adopting the mass
and stiffness then you know part of it
and therefore you can update also the
signal coefficient. So that's that's
exactly what is happening. I see.
So
I guess I'm surprised that the audience
doesn't have question. I I thought that
I was saying even controversial stuff
but Yeah, I mean yeah sometimes yeah, go
ahead.
So it's interesting.
Sorry sorry go ahead please go ahead
Constantinos please please go ahead.
Just a quick one regarding the case
where essentially you have a library of
functions that are unknown but it could
be that essentially you have an unknown
operator. It just doesn't have to be
functions. It can be differential
operators in there and the variety of
what you can have is
mind-boggling. I mean you can have
fourth order linear
ones etc. I mean
in the end if you don't have some
physical intuition on what could be
there
you can just throw the kitchen sink sink
at it. I don't know how
Yeah. helpful you can be.
I mean and and you know what? I think
that
the way in which I see it is that if you
don't know the physics
then basically Cindy will give you a
sort of set of polynomial. It will give
you a regressor. It will give you
something, right?
But of course the results will not be
generalizable. So that's the issue. And
and so I think that
Cindy is very powerful. It's
computationally very fast compared to
other routines or compared to other
strategy for nonlinear system
identification.
But of course it comes also with a price
in terms of knowledge.
And and indeed it might be that
physics-informed neural network or other
strategies even by using a GP for
representing those latent
force model is actually the best way to
go at.
Did you have Did you have in mind
something or something else that was
different or maybe No, I mean in in my
mind it's always been part of of
how when we have unknown
functional forms
or at least
completely open space, any approach
that's based on on training any form of
machine learning approach, whether it's
a neural network or anything else,
is deficient. I mean it may show really
nice results within the training space
Exactly.
beyond it, but I don't think that
if you change the parameters or even if
you just extend it long enough in time,
you're not going to see the pay the
price.
I I agree with you. I agree fully. And
that's the reason why we were interested
then to apply this type of approach in
which we used a GP and say, you know, we
don't know the functional form, we know
nothing.
And
again, though it's still
limited limited applicability. There is
so much that can be done. I am
I think that it's exciting to work in
this field because there is
lots of problems as you were saying,
Constantinos.
We have still work to do. Let's put it
this way.
I I essentially missed most of your
answer for some reason because my WebEx
croaked, but I guess I'll hear I'll hear
the recording. There's no need for you
to repeat. Thank you.
Okay. Thank you so much, Constantinos.
Yeah, Philip, what do you want? Yeah,
please go ahead for your question. Thank
you. Thank you, Alice, for the amazing
presentation. And uh yeah, I
like would like to say that I'm not
definitely an expert on uh physical
information learning, so my question can
be quite basic. Uh when I you were
talking about the general structure or
of a neural network in which you embed
the physical model, I saw that there was
a discrepancy bias, which was like the
end part, which is the part in which you
embedded the physical model itself. I
was wondering could that that like part,
that bias, must be always defined in a
closed-form analytical form, or can be
like also a finite element model that uh
in other reason another surrogate model
that we can run?
It can be whatever surrogate model you
want to um to use. And again, the point
is uh
about what you're trying to achieve. If
you want to get at the end of it uh the
partial differential equation, maybe and
you want to have something that is
generalizable, that can be applied in in
different uh settings, for different
input condition, for different initial
condition, then it's better to have
actually
information about the physics rather
than a reduced-order model that might
not map correctly. But in principle, you
can use anything there, indeed.
Okay, so if I'm looking more at a
specific case, I can even use a finite
element model, for example, of the
structure that I'm analyzing to draw
some physi- like to enhance the neural
network itself?
Yes. Uh the thing that will happen
though is uh how you write the this
architecture, considering that you have
this partial knowledge of the finite
element. So, what is then your input and
your output layer, basically? And what
are the operators
doing to the rest? So,
that's the only thing that you should
watch out there. Okay.
If I may just
sort of comment on this, the advantage
of putting the
government governing equations as we
know them in the loss function is that
within the usual at least neural network
frameworks
you get differentiation as a something
that comes in
easily
and you can just put the differential
form of the equations in the loss
function and calculate it as is
quite nicely. That was one of the nice
things about PINNs when they first
appeared. So,
there's a certain advantage to not
having to put in another finite element
model in there
when you have equations that you can
differentiate.
I think that Philip really was applying
it with a finite element. That's why I
was giving the sort of political
response that if you want you can but
then you have to change everything else.
Okay, that's perfect. Okay, that's good.